de l'histoire autochtone,
qui commence demain, une maison
d'édition de Wendake lance
une initiative pour encourager
la lecture de livres
L'objectif est
- Moi, je suis un peu dépassé
par ça, honnêtement!
- Le journaliste et écrivain
innu Michel Jean est encore
étonné par le succès
de son roman "Kukum", écoulé
à près de 80 000 exemplaires.
Ce livre inspiré de l'histoire
de son arrière-grand-mère
est allé droit au coeur
des lecteurs.
MICHEL JEAN,
écrivain et journaliste innu
- Et je reçois encore à chaque
jour au moins 10-15-20 messages
de gens qui l'ont lu et qui
me disent : "Je savais pas que
ça s'était passé comme ça.
Je suis content d'avoir lu
votre livre, Monsieur Jean."
T'sais, chaque jour encore, là!
- En plus de Michel Jean,
les auteures Naomi Fontaine,
Marie-Andrée Gill,
Natasha Kanapé-Fontaine et
Joséphine Bacon font briller
la littérature autochtone.
Devant une telle abondance de
talents, les éditions Hannenorak
lance la première édition
de l'événement "En juin :
je lis autochtone".
DANIEL SIOUI, co-fondateur
des éditions Hannenorak
- Je pense que c'est
une illumination qu'on a eue,
cette année, moi et ma
conjointe, avec tout ce qui se
passe, cette année, on entend
tellement parler des Premières
Nations qu'on s'est dit :
il fallait profiter du mois
de juin pour essayer
de faire connaître
encore plus la littérature
des Premières Nations.
- Kwè...
- Une douzaine de personnalités
vont partager leurs suggestions
pour ce mois de la littérature
autochtone. Pour la poète
innue du Lac-Saint-Jean
Marie-Andrée Gill,
l'événement est symbolique.
MARIE-ANDRÉE GILL
poète et auteure innue
- Pendant tellement longtemps,
notre histoire a été occultée.
Puis là, maintenant, bien,
les gens sont prêts et les gens
des Premières Nations aussi sont
prêts, fait que ça se rencontre.
- Ce mois de la littérature
autochtone est aussi porté
par un vent de changement
dans les librairies.
Ici, les auteurs
des Premières Nations
occupent une place de choix.
MARIO LAFRAMBOISE
libraire, Librairie Monet
- Il y a une grande demande
pour ça. Il y a vraiment,
maintenant, si je peux dire,
il y a des best-sellers
de littérature autochtone,
ce qui est vraiment
une très bonne nouvelle.
- Sur une belle lancée,
Michel Jean attribue en partie
son succès au contexte actuel.
- Le France-Québec, ça a été
comme un révélateur. Mais entre
les deux est arrivée l'affaire
Joyce Echaquan, je pense,
qui a le coeur et les esprits
de beaucoup de Québécois,
qui soudainement, se sont dit...
ils se sont rendus compte
qu'ils étaient en retard
un peu sur ça.
- Cette rencontre entre
écrivains autochtones
et de nouveaux lecteurs
nous démontre une page à la fois
que la littérature est
un vecteur de dialogue
et d'empathie.
Ici Louis-Philippe Ouimet,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.